hey guys how's it going if you're
looking for the second video today
unfortunately this is it I will go ahead
and make the excuse that I'm very very
tired and actually don't have enough
time today was one heck of a day
I started out great the cyndago guys are
officially in LA so I had to help them
find a new apartment and it's very close
to where I am now which means those
sketches that I told you about are going
to be coming very soon but there's a lot
of road that needs to be paved to get to
that point so still a lot of work that
needs to be done but we're gonna get
there pretty soon the other thing was I
took a 3-hour acting class today and it
was the first one I've ever taken very
different from what I was expecting but
took a lot of time I learned some stuff
and I actually look forward to learning
a lot more in the future but what really
got to me today was there was some
poorly timed drama that really stirred
up some emotions in earlier this week on
on Monday I had to say goodbye to
someone that I that I care very much
about and I'd like to say that wasn't
weighing on me
but it was and I'm good at burying
things not super deep but as deep as
they need to be so they don't affect me
on a daily basis but sometimes it just
can't help it and like I couldn't
exactly say that I was up to the task of
recording videos anyway like I have time
but I don't have time to whip myself up
into the mood to do it cuz I'm not gonna
just plaster smile on my face and try to
muscle my way through videos like you
guys would be able to tell I have been
having a lot of fun making videos lately
but just today was a strange day for me
yeah I hope you guys understand this is
actually yesterday you're you know
seeing now but in other news there's one
very important things that I wanted to
tell you guys about the nominee people
know about there is a charity livestream
that I'm going to be doing by myself
this Saturday in two days from when you
see this video Saturday I believe it's
the 21st I think it is either way this
the Saturday that you see after this
there's going to be a charity livestream
I have I'm very excited for this I have
a Super Nintendo emulator and I
downloaded a bunch of my old favorite
games the type of games that I used to
play with my brother as a kid and I'm
very eager because I'm gonna start with
Super Mario World which is one of my
all-time favorite games from a kid and I
am so happy to be able to do this and I
don't know why I didn't do it before
because you know usually when I do these
left simple on myself I usually look I
gotta get this game or this game or one
thing or another but something really
tickles me about just being able to sit
down and play a game that's very very
close to my heart and it's one of the
best things about games is like they're
not just like movies they you remember
they're their experiences that you've
lived so even the small ones that didn't
really matter that weren't the Super
Mario World so long as they may they
meant something to your life then
they'll mean something to your life for
your whole life you know you'll REM
you'll remember that for years and years
and years and when you get to relive it
again I think that's something really
special so I hope you will join me this
Saturday we're going to be raising money
for the depression and bipolar Alliance
which is a very highly rated charity for
the treatment and research of depression
and bipolar disorder for those people
that suffer through it and I and I know
I know that weirdly it's a touchy
subject because some people are very
skeptical about depression and bipolar
in in you know in a whole sense and how
some mental illness illnesses are
treated with I don't know almost disdain
mental illnesses need to come a long way
before they're treated on the same level
as physical illnesses but if I can do
anything to help because I know that
I've had so many emails and letters from
people telling me that my videos have
not cured their depression but at least
allowed them to see some light so that
they don't
feel trapped in the darkness in their
mind you know and and say what you will
about whether it's true or not or if
they're just crying for attention like I
don't care if you think that because
there are people that really do need
help and it's more than just a cry for
help it's it's life that they have to
live and you know I'm not saying that
I'm depressed cuz I had a bad day that's
not what I'm saying like a one bad day
does not the press make but you know I I
sympathize with them and I understand it
and I know so much more about it now
that I've been a beacon of hope for some
of these people and I know that I know
there's been a lot of really wordy heavy
stuff going on in the past week or so
ever since I hit six million tonight I
didn't mean to do it again but it's just
been a weird snowstorm of things
happening in my life all the wrong and
right time and so I I also wanted you
guys to know about this charity lesson
because I don't think I formally
announced it or if I did I can't
remember it and it's coming up in a few
days and I want you guys to know about I
want you guys to support it so please
join me this Saturday for livestream I
will get some sleep after this not that
I've been lacking sleep I've actually
been doing really great on my schedule
it's just that you know every once in a
while you'll get a bad day and I hope
that when you guys get a bad day my
videos are able to help you in some way
so thank you guys so much for watching
thank you guys so much for being here
and thank you for understanding that
some days I just need to take a moment
to relive things oh and also I thought
about this before I started recording
this video what would sometimes I do
want to have a bad days I actually look
at some of the older older videos that
I've done and I look at some of the
things that I've done in the past and
I look back in myself and I see this
baby-faced version of me and I remember
you know I remember cuz it was all like
a big part of my life and I remember you
know the moments that I went through and
the worries that I had and you know the
triumphs that I went through and you
know it all comes back to me and it's
all very important to me it's crazy to
think because it's just like three years
ago that I started doing YouTube and
it's somehow come to this and somehow
come to me being in front of all you
guys explaining away why I am late on a
video or I don't have a video up but uh
yeah just thank you guys again and
because I went back into the old videos
I assembled this little playlist that is
going to be linked in the description
below it's some of my favorite old
videos the ones that I go to when I feel
down and I need a little pick-me-up and
a reminder of where I started so I hope
you enjoy that playlist these videos I
hand-picked because they're very near
and dear to me and some of them you
might not have seen like many of you may
not have seen sorry excuse me
like some of you like may thoroughly
enjoy them some of you may think I'm an
awkward young lad who is still new to
the YouTube game but hopefully some of
you get some enjoyment about this I
meant this just to be a quick message so
I'm going to end it rather quickly thank
you guys again please click the link in
the description below for the playlist
of the videos that cheer me up and I
hope you guys will join me this Saturday
I really do because I'm very much
looking forward to so thank you again
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye bye